Jacob decided to surprise his parents
that here here's a sophomore at Lewis &
Clark University in Portland Mia
convinced his mom that he was going to
stay there for spring break but that
Friday he showed up at home to spend the
whole week with his family now it should
have been a great week restful relaxing
but Saturday night as he walked home
with some friends a man pulled up
demanded to know Jacobs gang affiliation
and shot him three times before he could
answer that was homicide number 12 last
year in San Francisco by year end there
have been 68 others there were 108 rapes
burglaries assaults thefts all in for
every 100,000 people in the city there
were more than 5,000 crimes and that was
right at the US average but there are
men and women working really hard on
this more than a million officers and
fifty billion dollars in operating
budgets and these are the numbers that
we hold our Police Department's
accountable to crime per capita is their
net income this is their main success
metric great right well actually there's
a really big problem with that see crime
is impacted by all sorts of things
outside of a departments control things
like population density education income
as a result our main way of measuring
the success of a police department isn't
actually very good at telling us how
they're doing as such our departments
are out there doing pretty dramatically
different things financially
strategically tactically with no real
way to say what's working and what is it
this time last year while it's still in
consulting either chance to partner with
Dallas Police Department to tackle this
problem and after six months of coming
through annual reports of doing a lot of
statistical analysis and interviewing
chiefs and officers across the nation
we're actually able to
to isolate some of the impact that
police department's do have on crime and
what we uncovered was a fascinating
story about incentives and impact at the
highest level a police department can
spend its resources in two very basic
ways you've got crime response now these
are things like your 911 response teams
and your entire investigations unit and
then you have crime prevention which is
things like your community engagement
and all your patrol officers now besides
crime per capita we actually hold our
department strictly accountable to a
couple other measures one of the main
ones is response times which is how long
it takes an officer to get to your door
after you call 911 what's really true
about that as a metric well it's
entirely crime response oriented and
sure enough we hold our departments
almost exclusively accountable to the
crime response side but what we
uncovered as we started to isolate that
impact was that it's actually a focus on
crime prevention that's really making a
difference and as our standards on these
metrics have gotten higher and higher
over time we've essentially created a
system where we're forcing our
departments to prioritize the side of
their business that doesn't contribute
to the bottom line now this tension is
very real on a day-to-day basis imagine
with me that you're a patrol officer
it's 11pm and you're on your beat in
your neighborhood you've been on
assignment here for over a year and
you've actually really gotten another
community that's actually why you're
here tonight when your contacts call
there's a little bit of unrest some
unresolved dispute and potentially a
high chance of violence now crime
prevention at it's very best you're out
there knocking on doors meeting with
community members keeping the peace and
then your radio goes off there was a
theft a couple blocks down it's nothing
serious maybe a couple iPods a PC but
someone just called it in because they
need a police report so they can file
for insurance now you don't want to go
but now that that call has come in
that response time clock is ticking and
you know it's going to show up in your
review and that's going to show up in
your sergeants and his lieutenants so
you go and when you get there you get
another call and then another one
officer I talked to describe this as
being a slave to the radio now who knows
what happened back in your neighborhood
that time maybe it was nothing or maybe
that was Jacob's neighborhood maybe it
was that night you wanted to be there
but unfortunately you had a job to do
this is the tension between crime
response and crime prevention and too
often it ends up being a tension between
making the grade and making an impact so
how do we fix it well let me tell you
about Chief Ed Flynn chief Flynn is one
of those grizzled old men of the law
he's all right angles whether it be its
personality or that freshly starched
uniform this is a guy who probably
belongs in Gotham City but in 2008 he
landed in milwaukee as a new chief of
police of one of the nation's most
dangerous cities now chief Flynn made it
clear on day one that prevention is his
big priority see the chief believes in
what he calls the 6010 rule and that's
at ten percent of criminals and
neighborhoods are responsible for sixty
percent of crime his message to his
officers was crystal clear no your ten
percent find the underlying issues
beneath these pockets of chron and solve
them rude amount and things changed in
his first year the number of traffic and
pedestrian stops in Milwaukee doubled
but during the same time period the
number of tickets written was actually
cut in half see officers were being
proactive with their community but they
weren't chasing tickets they were
building relationships this wasn't stop
and frisk this was stopped and asked how
are things going how are things in your
neighborhood how can I help especially
in those ten per cents
first even though there were so many
more interactions the number of citizen
complaints that year actually went down
then crime plummeted especially when you
control for some of those variables from
2007 to 2011 crime went down everywhere
in the US by about fifteen percent in
Milwaukee it was more than 30 that's
thirty percent less burglaries thirty
percent less theft thirty percent less
murder well what's crazy is if you go
back and you read the newspaper
headlines from this period you get a
completely different narrative response
times go up in Milwaukee and that's the
rub the metrics that we have in place
are at best incomplete but they're
probably just wrong sure chief Flynn can
plow through it by sheer force of
personality but what about the rest of
our departments we need change we need a
new paradigm for thinking about policing
for our city halls and our Chiefs that
means redesigning these metrics such
that they're aligned with the
department's mission metrics that
reinforce prioritizing the right things
but that's not all see in those cities
that I saw where they were really having
an impact on crime prevention was never
just a department activity it was a
partnership with the community with us
the fact is there's something that every
single one of us in this room can do as
well an engaged community that views the
police as a partner is the most powerful
tool in fighting crime so what I'm
asking is really pretty simple as
community members as community leaders
get to know your departments at home at
work at school learn what their
priorities are no your ten percents and
ultimately become a partner in
prevention so that you can help your
departments stop fighting crime and
start stopping it thank you
you